[Musique]
cet étudiante de 20 ans que nous
appellerons Manal a accepté de nous
parler anonymement depuis la mort en
détention de Marsa Amini comme bien des
iraniennes et les descendus dans la rue
[Musique]
comme c'est concitoyennes Manal brave la
répression pour exprimer son ras-le-bol
[Musique]
friture
elle puisse son énergie dans les paroles
de cette chanson devenue virale écrite
par un artiste de la nouvelle scène un
hymne à la révolte et un appel à
l'unisson
les femmes se sont toujours battues
toutes seules contre le régime elles
n'ont jamais eu enfin très peu très peu
de soutien des hommes mais c'est la
première fois qu'on voit un soutien
massif de la part des hommes pour la
cause féminine
achiraz c'est autre lycéenne de 18 ans
avec qui nous avons échangé ne se fait
aucune illusion sur son sort si jamais
il est arrêtée
mais pour le gouvernement iranien s'est
dissidence doit être rééduqué le
ministre de l'Éducation annoncé que les
détenus seront placés dans des centres
psychiatriques on les traite comme des
folles ce type de comportement que la
République islamique est en train de
manifester envers les opposants iraniens
et les opposantes et digne de 18e siècle
on est en 21e siècle et ils sont en
train de se comporter comme les régimes
moyenâgeux
a déjà eu affaire à la police des mœurs
[Musique]
mais par dessus tout et nous confie
qu'elle veut pouvoir marcher dans la rue
et sentir les rayons du soleil sur son
cou
[Musique]